five five running back is turning heads
at the Cowboys Camp his name is deucevon
and even though he went in the last
round of the draft he's proving that he
could be a major playmaker for the
Cowboys this season Medusa's incredible
story didn't just start right now it
started when he got the call from an
unexpected person during last year's
draft now most players get the call from
their team's GM or owner but Deuce
didn't he picked up the phone to hear
his dad on the other line asking if he
wanted to come with him to work Deuce's
Dad Chris is a scout for the Cowboys and
he was able to give deuce the best news
he could have ever asked for